hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to i'm on observation duty
four
four i don't know what three two and one
are but this one is a horror game that
got really good reviews on steam and it
seems to be like an inspection kind of
like looky loo thing hint do not seek
the secret it will come to you i don't
like that level phase i've never
goes for transparent true intruders or
not i've never played this game before i
don't know what the level phases are one
needs sharp eyes and good memories to
serve
oh no
oh no i'm [ __ ]
all right let's go to the city house oh
what
oh am i supposed to remember [ __ ] that
happens
nice
what
what do you mean
attention employee anomalies have been
previously cited in the monitored house
pay extremely close attention to the
surveillance camera footage
file an anomaly report asap when you
notice something has changed well i mean
i noticed the
tissues and lotion right there two
bottles even well this one's hand
sanitizer but i doubt that
okay so i'm supposed to remember this i
don't like that painting ah
okay some kind of sauna
has anything changed here there are
three books on the bed
two things on the wall the curtains are
closed
that painting was there before there's
four magazines tissues a lot of tissues
in this house the blinds are open
oh
how am i supposed to know anything
something gonna jump out of me
fan is spinning
well this is making me extremely
uncomfortable why do i feel like stomach
is going to jump out at me
oh i don't like this
wait wasn't that different i said wait
wait
hang on okay kitchen
wasn't the
uh
painting anomaly
was that different
report pending was that wrong was it
wrong i thought that was different
i might be wrong
no no ah it was the same as it was
before okay so yeah what are the types
of anomalies we got abyss presence
camera malfunction distortion door
opening closing
ghost intruder light anomaly
disappears object movement okay
so it will be the paintings doors
objects
literal ghosts
literal intruders god it's quiet
did that move
object move
was that always like that
was that always like that nah oh god
damn it kitchen wait sauna
damn it
okay
i don't like it
i don't know what's happening and i
don't know how long i
need to wait for something to happen
[Music]
wait wait wait wait wait painting
anomaly wait
was there a shelf here but that that i
would have noticed that i would have
noticed that no god damn it i did the uh
a hallway
i would have noticed that i would have
noticed that that's
definitely different
there's a painting
[Music]
i got one oh anomaly fixed how in the
world did i how did you do that
how
how did you do how did you do that how
did you do that
how would you fix an anomaly in this i
thought this was like security footage
didn't you say it was footage as in
previously recorded
is this live
where am i
she always sat there was that always
there
extra object was that always there
i don't remember it maybe it's dark so
oh did i hit the study i don't think i
oh no what about
why what happened what was that
what happened what happened what
happened what happened
what happened what
wait study uh noise is there like a
noise anomaly
what was what what
happened
oh i see wait uh abyss presents in the
bedroom
i guess maybe ghost
maybe a ghost maybe an abyss maybe a
ghost it might be i think that might be
a ghost now that i'm starting to think
it's a it's a ghost this ghost
there's a ghost and there's a ghost in
the bedroom fix it fix it
yes thank you
okay good anomaly fixed great all good
all good oh good
let's give me the heebies
maybe even the jeebies
strange
oh my god okay living room there's a
ghost
there's a mumbly ghost
there's a
ghost
hi okay thank you please purge it out of
this reality thank you
preach
biggest preach
huge preach
i don't know oh well with the the blinds
those blinds were closed before okay uh
other
those blinds were no they were open
it was the bedroom ones that were closed
i'm an idiot
well i'm gonna let my guard down and
relax
sure hope nothing bad happens while i'm
all vulnerable and whatnot
oh wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa hey hang on study door opening
this is an emergency morning we are
receiving readings of multiple active
anomalies in your area what do you mean
please locate the anomalies and send
reports asap what do you mean multiple
i've been looking i haven't seen
anything what are you talking about
what
what was that always like that was that
always like that was it is was it always
like that
i don't know what do you mean there was
a door that was all i saw
what do you mean
in the hallway painting anomaly what do
you mean what are you talking is there
something downstairs
i can't see
nothing
anything no painting
i don't know what you're talking about
you said multiple anomalies and i don't
know what you mean there's five wait
in the living room there's uh uh extra
object
there was only four there before i
remember distinctly there was four i
counted them
what do you mean oh god
oh god
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you mean painting painting anomaly
it's a painting anomaly it's a painting
anomaly there's a painting anomaly there
okay definitely that's gonna get god
thank you
you're just making me paranoid aren't
you you're making me think that there's
multiple but i have not seen
multiple because i do not think there
are multiple i thought there were only
four there unless i miscounted from the
get-go
whoa what was that whoa what was that
what is wait camera malfunction
camera camera malfunction or flashing is
flashing lights
something else
what is that
okay it must be an abyss light anomaly
light anomaly
thank
you okay
i don't know why this is so stressful
it's very stressful
wait a minute whoa
whoa
whoa whoa there was no one on that
tracks there was no one on those tracks
there was no one
there was not a oh you better back off
oh you better back off that was subtle
that was subtle i don't like that
oh i don't like that
why was there someone in that painting
where they're gonna be walking closer
and closer to me until they got me
object movement
object movement optic movement alpha
check it to movement
thank you
okay
guys if you see something let me know
because i'm
not seeing
i'm not seeing anything
oh whoa what is that what is that
bedroom is there a noise anomaly other
what's going on
what does that
sound what is that about
what do you mean
manny
it's over
i think what it meant too many
i saw none
what
what do you mean
i'm going to the country house
i hate that
what is that about
okay thank you
great
warning yeah i know
attention employee anomalies okay i get
it i get it oh this seems tougher i
don't like these things
oh my god is that the amount of detail
that i need to pay attention to know
that those things have changed
that's
that's not fair maybe i should just like
just in case if i don't find anything i
should say like object movement because
that's probably going to be the thing
that really gets me
this thing's just moving
i have no idea
i have no idea
i have no idea
i don't know
oh my god okay
well that clearly is not right good god
thank you okay
glad that that wasn't there wait a
minute wait a minute door door
dude
that door was not open was it open was
it open the whole time it might have
been open
that might have been open
that might have been open okay what
about in here extra object
maybe
either extra object or like moved object
who knows
damn it what about like uh
object movement
i feel like that wasn't always open but
what do i know
oh god hi okay cool painting anomaly
great
that's good
thank
you how about living room painting
anomaly as well how many times has that
been happening like
a painting it's been just completely
messed up but i just look glossed over
it
what is that in the back what's going on
it's either what's with those shoes what
are those shoes what am i seeing what am
i seeing what have i got what do we got
extra extra object was that always there
maybe
damn it
i'm just gonna do painting anomaly just
in case
i'm missing something there's definitely
something here
wait a minute wait wait a minute
wait a minute
was that always no
no
no no no
was it i don't know
i knew it
i
knew it
i knew it
was that always like that wait wait
kitchen kitchen kitchen uh object
movement that was that was that
something was different here no maybe it
was the same i don't know but that
painting also doesn't look right does
that look great i don't know what about
painting anomaly in the kitchen
whoa
what did i just
what did i just see i s what
what did i just there was something
there
do i report that there was something
going on in here in the gallery
distortion was a distortion
was it always snowing here
was it always it wasn't always snowing
outside
i know that's probably just a very
natural occurrence and of course it
would weather could
change
oh sh
wait
what's that was that shelf always like
that
object disappearance could also be a
thing
ah damn it
goddamn what about outside one of these
rocks maybe
object movement and i'll try object
disappearance next
could be i feel like something's changed
here i don't know why i keep thinking
that something's changed here
object let's try object disappearance
because i haven't done that
object movement
my god i i get it oh hi
hello
how are you doing
isn't it a little cold to be naked
i get it malta i know multiple anomalies
here i get that i understand
is there something different about the
paintings in the gallery maybe
i don't know
oh my god oh my god is there anything
different about this place
[Music]
i have no idea there are anomalies here
clearly
extra object
stop smiling at me like that with that
smug smile
whoa whoa oh god
oh oh okay there's a freaking ghost in
the window how did i not notice that
how in the world did i not notice that
okay well that's one i'm still very
behind
i'm sure
what is is that what what
kitchen abyss presence
maybe
i don't even know what abyss presence
means
what does that even mean
i know i'm gonna oh my god how am i this
bad
how am i this bad living room extra
object i feel like maybe that wasn't on
the shelf before
i don't know i it's like every time i
come back to these things i see
something new and i don't know if it's
just because i've literally never seen
it before
or it's new
wait a minute gallery
movement that was on the left clearly
that's obvious
i'm only catching the obvious ones but
at least it's something is that
was there always something on the floor
there library
extra object either that or movement
maybe
i feel like i would have noticed that
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
well i don't know if that sound pertains
just to the location that i'm in like
hey idiot there's something here hey
markiplier specifically you the idiot
known as markiplier
you're an idiot i know i get that how
about painting anomaly
something going on in here
something going on in here
definitely not what else is here
what an intruder
oh my god
i'm i lose i lose there's too many
anomalies and i just can't deal i don't
know how to deal so wait wasn't it
wait outside extra object
was
oh my i'm doomed i'm doomed i'm doomed
they're gonna eat my brains i'm doomed
i'm doomed i am doomed
i'm doomed
i'm doomed
i'm whoa hey that smiling face of yours
looking good
um
that's strange
thank you okay that's one
outside extra object is there always
five rocks over there
i keep doing extra object outside i
don't know why
okay once i lose this i'm just gonna i
should just start saying out loud okay
painting or we got none something what
is that what wait what
what is that is that always
wha what is that i don't even know
it's a face of some kind was that always
like that
okay
uh bench chairs sugar something
passports beer sugar can
uh let's just go extra object i guess
yeah i'm doomed
i'm doomed
god damn it it's over
you lose
okay i only got seven that time i am
terrible
i'm terrible okay i know it's probably
best for me to go back to the same place
but i'm just i want to see them all okay
the station okay what are we dealing
with we got benches on the side we got a
rack of uh
brochures we got a painting of a dude we
got another painting of a dude we got
two
things at the end of the hallway this
yada yada
okay we got laptop board screens windows
fan i'm looking okay
looking not a lot of light in this room
but we got a laptop with thing on the
screen we got three papers on that side
with a book two papers on this side
and a drink and a drink or a candle or
whatever that is we got a painting of a
naked lady we got some uh pictures of
naked ladies we got three shampoo
bottles i don't know if these are gonna
change right away and i should have been
looking we got another painting of a
naked lady i'm noticing a theme here wet
floor floor is not dry three soap
dispensers two urinals hiding in the
shadows and one slightly shiny thing
there we gotta jail two toilets that's
strange
it's supposed to be like that
it's supposed to be two toilets and
another two bottles of water one
bag another bottle over there and i can
see a little bit of the
thing there okay we have two paintings
of the dude
brochures the stairs yada yada
it's all the same
that was there yeah
okay laptop two four
things
painting pictures
thing three shampoo balls is there an
extra
i don't think that there's an extra
object in here that's that's one way for
me to know if if anything is not
supposed to be here
three soap bottles toilet
naked lady
two one two toilets bag whatever that is
down there
was that always like that down there
hallway
oh they're different corpse
i don't know extra object let's keep
keep that going
light outside was it was it bright
outside
okay
there oh
that move that move that move that moved
toilet
object movement
okay got that keep looking two one two
one bag
got it
painting painting
wait
is that always like that
i can't tell what that is but
picture anomaly
was there always that thing on there i
don't know am i supposed to look at that
my new detail probably yeah
how about in the office picture anomaly
pictures what am i looking at over there
it's so dark i can't see it's a smudge
maybe
wouldn't oh no that
what what
that that is that a
[Music]
is that a is that a dude
or an intruder
there is someone standing there or
that's a picture of a thing is that a
picture is that a dude is that a dude
intruder
or was there a painting of a naked guy
there that i didn't see because it's uh
am i do i not playing without brightness
oh god
i don't know i don't wha toilet paper i
can't see sir can i turn up the
brightness
oh my god i can see
oh my god this whole time i've been like
looking at nothing in the darkness
that's too bright
like that there we go
oh was there always a painting there was
there always a painting there
i see i thought that was like a dude
standing there
oh
i don't know if this automatically means
i'm gonna be better at the game but what
wait
no
no no no no
wait was that always knocked over was
this always open wait jail
door open and closing was that always
open
maybe that's why it was weird to me but
also everything was dark so i have no
idea
what about object movement
i hear something
i mean
i heard something else besides that that
came right as i said that i know that
seems like a coincidence but i did not
say
something did move
was it the bottle knocked over
maybe there's an extra object in the
toilet because i i don't know if that
fire extinguisher was there or what i
have no idea couldn't see it
oh hi
hello
how are you
i'm hoping corpse i don't know why i'm
hoping that
don't know why a dead body would be
preferable
thank you take that away please thank
you
great
good
has this moved again
well i don't know what it said it fixed
an anomaly for object movement here but
i don't know what moved
it just so happened that i got it
let me just go ahead and send reports
for all of them just in case
oh oh oh that is i noticed that okay
office picture anomaly i definitely
noticed that i feel like i would have
noticed that even if the brightness
wasn't up but i notice it
thank you
okay
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa that
locker room door opening
was that always like that oh maybe i'm
crazy i have like smudges on my screen i
don't know what's what
no
what is
is that what am i looking at what what
am i looking at are you smiling at me
what is that
obvious presence
right there what is that what is that
what is that it's not a smile you better
not be a smile
you put your hell out of here
oh no it's the shelf
it's a little bit of light hitting the
[ __ ] what is that
that's dust on my screen as well i'm i
literally i haven't dusted my monitor in
years i'm
i'm sorry
oh chairs chairs object movement in the
conference room
why are you all looking at me chairs huh
ain't no looking at me
don't look at me
thank you
okay
i really thought that was like teeth in
the darkness
i'm sorry
wait soap
object missing
toilet object disappearance
there were three i remember there being
three let me count everything else that
i counted there were two bottles one one
bag apparently there was a bag there
let me just make sure there isn't like
an extra object in the jail
just in case
this was like that maybe there's no i
don't think so this was here the
paintings are there that third painting
is definitely there
um
object disappearance maybe
pen
paper
yeah i should check for object
disappearances everywhere just in case
because
that's something that i believe that i
would not notice
there's a painting there
is that smudge
hey let me i don't know if there's a
picture anomaly
oh come on what
what
oh does that just mean it's two o'clock
probably
oh hello well that's different um
[Music]
uh other tha i don't know how to qualify
that one
that's a little odd
oh my god wait what the hell is on that
screen what the hell is on that screen
wait what zoom in is that is that smile
mouth
is that smile mouth
is that mouth up smile
does that smile mouth
is that always like that rotate i
believe that's something weird okay
was that always there what's that
why do i keep saying things like that
extra object
i don't know
oh hi
okay toilet
um
door opening and closing i guess you
could call it that
hmm
that's suspicious
okay
there was not a chair behind there
jail extra object
was there a chair behind that there
might have been share behind that
i was right
i'm a genius
i am
so smart
there's got to be some ghosts around
here
i ain't afraid of no ghosts
god i know i know i know i know i know
i know
i know
i can't see anything it's an i spy game
i'm not cut out for
i know i know i know
i know
i don't know what else to do
i don't know
oh what the hell is going on there whoa
whoa whoa whoa uh uh what do you what do
you i i don't even know how to
it's moving i'll give it that it's uh
it's a it's moving um
i if that doesn't work i'll call it an
other uh i'm going with other i can't
explain
what
oh
houston
we got a problem of that
oh thank you
it's still it's you didn't it's still
doing the it's still doing the i don't
know how to explain this uh you know how
his just growing exponentially it's just
still doing that
are you sure
what did i just see out of that okay i
didn't see anything
um
distortion
does that mean there was an other
anyway
did did that get that
[Music]
oh okay
that's what destroyed there was just
another anomaly here
what does that mean
[Music]
what do you mean other what what what
was there what happened
what
i
excuse me
uh you okay what's what's in the box
all right cool thanks i think that's the
same
wait there were more books on that shelf
weren't there
no goddammit conference room object
disappearance wasn't there wasn't there
more like right here
am i crazy did this guy always have a
cool stick
i feel like he did
i was right let me try a picture anomaly
while i look at other things
this is all the same ish
okay nothing there i got quite a few i
wonder how far away i am from dying now
oh oh
oh okay that's clear anomaly let me do
some other ones in places too because
i don't know it just seems like if there
was an other
here
there might be others else
um
uh
i don't know explain this we got
i think it can only be called a camera
malfunction here uh
i don't know how cameras do this oh
what
what
we i didn't even know that could happen
was that the abyss was that the abyss
was it that the abyss i'm gonna guess
that was the abyss
i'm just gonna guess that was the abyss
and i sh i should have
done something about the abyss okay
everything is still the same everything
is the same as it was so i should be
able to remember this still three back
there
so these are all the same so long as i
keep this in mind
everything should be fine
yeah i get it
i get i'm just gonna do this one more
time
just because i'm actually interested in
this
oh okay
start on me there
okay hi you having fun there
you having fun there mr chair i think i
actually caught something moving
on camera which is very interesting so
you could stay on one
and you would definitely see when
something happens
so that's good to know
oh
well that's not right
that up there
it's one o'clock yay
this is not moved has it
oh it just did uh fix it now fix it now
it's there it's there's there fix it fix
it fix it thank you i predicted you i
knew you were going to do that before
you even did it you fool
you fool
maybe disappear oh two o'clock okay i'm
fine
i'm fine i've been finding a few
maybe not all of them but i've been
oh
what did i
object movement object disappearance in
the jail what i don't know now because
i don't see it or it's there again i
guess
wait wasn't there something else in the
hallway here wasn't there like something
right there am i crazy no
maybe maybe there was another chair
there
nah
just in case
i'm just doing object disappearances in
all these just in case there's something
gone
no that's all good
locker room object disappearance
i should also do object movement
but whatever
there was a disappearance
i did it
i'm the best i would never have even
known it was gone what was gone i don't
know maybe something up there i wasn't
really checking those
okay now i'm gonna do movements
and then i'll do extra objects
oh
there was apparently something moved
there
don't know what
something was okay now i'm gonna do
extra object all right extra object star
from the jail
i haven't found something in a while
with my own eyes i've done my random
checks and i've found things but
that was a random check for extra object
in the office which apparently there was
i don't know i guess i should look at
the things as i'm doing them okay
i think i've done all of these
i guess it's time just to go back over
again and do object movement
her object disappearance i don't
remember
oh picture anomaly in the conference
room hi
how you doing welcome
my name is markiplier and welcome
glad to have you here thank you
those are easy it's the tiny things that
are tough
i feel like i've got a good read on
everything in each room but i don't know
three o'clock hey i'm doing good i
haven't even gotten that warning yet
that's great
that's oh oh oh oh oh oh oh chairs
oh no i'm getting the warning
this is an emergency warning
we are receiving my friend
what about others can i do other checks
please
[Music]
i don't know i'm not seeing anything
there's like a whole slew of categories
of of anomalies that i just
i haven't even experienced yes i don't
know what to mean
how to find door
door
door
door
door
door that door nah oh come on
i'm gonna die oh object missing here
definitely a lot of stuff happens in the
conference room
confidence room
a confoundence room
become flamsteen's room
oh picture anomaly that's creepy how you
doing
good to see you
damn might be some extra objects around
here
i'm not seeing them
what was that
i heard something
locker room what did i hear i heard
something
oh that ain't good okay
toilet picture anomaly
ah
fix it fix it fix it fix it thank you
i gotta find more i'm not finding enough
i'm doomed
i'm gonna lose
i'ma lose i'ma lose
i'ma lose
because i don't know what i'm doing
after all this time staring at the same
goddamn rooms i can't figure out what's
going on
i got another one
i got another one let's just do object
hi
hello
what are you doing here
confidence room extra object
you're in the wrong level
you should be in that other place the
other house thank you
okay but these are all new anomalies i
don't think those are any of the ones
that i
already
had
jail movement
i thought you're always facing away
maybe
oh my god hi okay hallway uh i'm
thinking of corpse
i'm thinking
i'm thinking corpse i'm thinking it
oh four o'clock hey that's a new record
for me good great i am swimming in
anomalies i know
i know i'm just
flooded with anomalies i'm assuming that
there can be more than one anomaly at a
time
no matter where you are
i'm just gonna do others because i can't
see anything else
there was something there wait whoa
hi door
but also there was something here
what
was that
literally that wasn't that wasn't
that wasn't mine that
what was that there was something right
there i'm not crazy
am i crazy i might be crazy i don't know
it could be smudge
maybe i shouldn't do blind guessing
because it makes it so that i don't know
what it did and if i don't know what it
did then i couldn't possibly ever catch
it again in the future so i'm really
just doing myself a disservice
probably
guys
i might be dumb
wait
isn't that
did that move
did that move
i'm dumb okay guys i'm really dumb and i
just
i don't know
what i'm doing i don't know
why i'm doing it
i don't know
nothing i ain't got no clue and i'm
gonna die
there's probably like someone staring at
me from a window somewhere around here
right oh
got an anomaly in the locker room of an
extra object i wish i could have seen
that
i'm literally only blaming myself maybe
oh the better strategy which there is
time to do is to go to each room do all
the object reports
and then
that way i will see what happens right
that way i would know okay let's look
for any obvious ones first oh my god
obvious one
[Music]
hi
you get out
i know it's a locker room and that's
kind of the purpose of that
i made it to five somehow
uh let me just go ahead and here i'll do
all the
object disappearance i'll do them all in
the same room
i'm not i didn't pick the jail did i
what did i pick okay locker room well i
guess we'll do it here then because
anything else would be obvious any of
these other things with an intruder the
pictures they would be obvious
am i wrong
maybe and i should prioritize the ones
that have
more objects in them
to do these types of scans
and then the other ones
not that
how
i don't know
ooh 22 that's not bad
okay i'm gonna leave it at that i
actually played this for a lot longer
than i thought it would oh it was close
to the end ah damn it it doesn't matter
kind of interesting game very
interesting i'm actually surprised thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to try this for yourself link
is in the description check out other
scary games that i've done in my big
scary games playlist and as always i
will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]